the 21st century the U.S marriage rates
has six I know we're in the UK but I
used the U.S one the U.S marriage rate
has declined for more than eight
marriages per 1000 down to six marriages
per 1000 population in 2019. the
marriage rate is the lowest level since
the U.S government began keeping
marriage records for the country in
1867.
why aren't people getting married
anymore
because women don't know what men want
in marriage and the standard for men has
been the same and so
women also don't really know their
nature either so they kind of they
expect a lot from men when realistically
it's not really possible given the state
of like the economy because in the past
in the 1950s and and before that
like it was it was okay to be
hypergamous in a way because women
didn't really have much money so if a
guy makes uh I don't I don't know like
by those standards 30k a year that was
fine because they they were they were
still living with their parents but now
like women actually out earn men in many
in in certain industry I'm not sure but
I know that they go to college more than
than men do and so they want a man
that's more educated they want a man
that makes more money and like
realistically given their nature that
makes sense get due to history but it
doesn't make sense now because men and
women are competing and their standards
aren't lowering
what do you think
um
we're sorry my mind went somewhere else
can you repeat the question yeah why um
so marriage rates are lower than they've
ever been why aren't people getting
married anymore
um I'll say Society now in a a high
expectations
um I would say social media also like um
back in the day kind of a thing where
there's a lot of cheating nowadays
people are easily swayed both men and
women and I'll say social media plays a
big part now like Instagram and stuff
like that
um also now a lot of people know they're
worth I would say kind of them they
won't settle for just you beating me up
and stuff like that whereas back in the
day a lot of people would like they'll
compromise and stay but I know I'll say
some a lot of people know their value
yeah and more work kind of thing you
think people know their value yeah
sometimes yeah I agree I think that's I
think when no not the value part I I
agree I think the reason why men and
women aren't getting married anymore is
because of wokism yeah yeah I think
it'll work yeah okay go ahead I think
that's a big part of it and I also I
think it's a few things people don't
really know their roles and they don't
discuss that up front so when it doesn't
work out for them either way for the for
the Lady or the man
they they almost feel resentful and then
they they divorce and they think the
grass is going to be greener I think the
grass is grass is greener syndrome is
legitimately a thing it comes from like
social media and dating apps and
people have never had to commit like
they have to commit now because they
have so many options now yeah so I think
if you can commit now it says a lot more
than back in the day because back in the
day
you only really knew who was around you
in your town do you know what I mean you
couldn't if you're a baddie you know you
could get flown out to somewhere that
stuff like that just didn't happen you
know so
um for you because you've actually
um
seen dating change I'm sure over the
past like 20 30 years why did more
people get married before and why don't
they get married now
I think there was more stigma you
couldn't have kids outside of marriage
and it's for it to be okay I think
that's one thing and I think there was a
lot of pressure from families for you to
do the right thing nowadays you can
cohabitate for years you can have
children
in that in that partnership and not
really have stability although you might
think it's stability you might have been
with the same person for 10 years
but I think
um I don't see that as stability really
because a lot of people leave
relationships they go into another one
they create another family so I think
values have changed what people see as
the norm now has changed cohabitating is
the norm and even people that I know say
they would never think about marriage
they'll think about living with someone
but not marriage as the ultimate
commitment but my parents married that's
what I would look look to do because I
think it's the right thing for me even
though you know I'm at the age that I am
I still think it's it's the right thing
to do
do you think marriage a marriage is a
bad deal for men nowadays now that we
offer less than ever as women so the
average age of first marriage in the UK
is 31 so we don't have youth anymore
um Purity like I think most men would
pray for a girl with less than five
bodies nowadays uh where they used to
get virgins and on top of that the
divorce laws are very heavily favored
towards women where we can leave and
take half and there's you know sayings
like it's cheaper to keep her on top of
that if we leave we can also take the
kids and put them on child support
um would you say that if that marriage
is a bad deal for men today why would
they get married I said depending on who
you're marrying it'll be a bad deal
okay I think by and large you're you're
spot on with a lot of those points I
think one of the biggest ones is just
the the divorce because a lot of things
have been equalized for better for worst
why has that not reflected those things
and the divorce laws yeah yeah because
if they were
and I I'm speaking from someone who I
actually want to get married you know
and I think if you're a guy and you want
to get married maybe a prenup might be a
good idea if you're if you are of some
high amount of value
but I think it's an even bigger
sacrifice for a guy to make now than
ever before but because of that reason
like you could be in a relationship the
goal earns as much as you're more and
then your divorce and they get even more
right so it's I think that is I think
one of the biggest factors what would
you say
um so one why do you still want to get
married even with all of that and to
what would you say
um would you say a prenup is the
solution or are there other solutions
that you could think of from a guy's
point of view so I'd say prenup is part
of the solution and I'd also say that
um I like the idea of making a sacrifice
um I think a lot of the best things in
life come with sacrifices
and
also my mum and dad had me quite late in
life so they're kind of everyone I went
to school with their parents were
younger so they're an older generation
and I guess I maybe I'm a hopeless
romantic you know the the comments
section can rinse me for it I don't I
don't care but
I do yeah yeah they will yeah I'm sure
they I'm sure they will but I think
I'm confident in myself enough to still
Flex you know like Brendan Fraser if you
know the actor he had one of the worst
divorces ever I don't know all the
details but he's just come out with some
amazing movie right he's still flexing
because he knows he's still got it and I
think that shows confidence as a man
that if you can still make that
sacrifice and you can still earn after
you know do you think another solution
is just living together and never
getting married potentially yeah yeah I
think
I think kids in my opinion is the
ultimate commitment and then marriage
after that because you'll essentially
make you're passing your genes on with
someone else you're choosing to mix your
genes with someone but yeah I think
cohabitation is a solution you know
what's also a crazy thing is that um men
I don't think women really appreciate
how much of a sacrifice it is for men to
get married
um because one in four marriages are
sexless
um so it's like men go through all of
this stuff to get married and girls
won't even say that sex is you do but
rare like girls won't even admit that
sex is a duty like they don't even get
sex whenever they want yeah I think
again
I think a lot of people again I'm not
saying I'm perfect but that's why I
think truth is so important because if
you go into something saying these are
all roles this is what I expect from you
what do you expect from me and I'll say
okay I'll put a ring on it as long as
these things are in place if these
things are not in place no longer then
it's those are why I would divorce okay
um what about you guys what incentive do
you think men have to get married today
culturally though I mean our culture we
we have we still governed under our own
choices like I know Africans and some
Caribbeans Africans more they are gonna
marry they're not going to think about
doing prenups they're going to get
married
even if they had children outside of the
marriages they're still gonna get
married Caribbeans I'm not sure really
if we're kind of into getting married I
don't know when's the last time I went
to a wedding but like from an African
point of view yes they still get married
I just think that um
people are not traditional people are
untraditional and it's for the kids
right I think a lot of people in this
day and age think that they forget that
what is the function of marriage
I believe it's for the children you know
it's both of you saying till death do us
part and if you actually take the words
you say seriously which I don't think
I always I always think about that women
from the 1940s and 50s would like laugh
at us today because like they'd be like
oh you left because you weren't happy my
man had a whole family across town and I
stayed you know what I mean like that
used to happen like families would meet
at funerals and even
um you know I have some relatives that
like kind of you know stayed together
through cheating and like all this stuff
but like nowadays like girls will just
sleep because they're not happy which is
which is crazy especially when you have
kids it's not about you it's so crazy
and that's why I don't think men have
any incentive anymore to get married
like because
initially men would marry for sex
because women want a commitment so and
women they wouldn't give sex unless
there was a commitment and then they
want someone that can cook and clean and
maintain a home that's good with
children and a lot of women don't want
children
um and they they wanted Purity like they
wanted a virgin and women aren't virgins
anymore and then add the divorce courts
on top of that I mean and then as a
society as well like there's no shame
with divorce it almost seems like a life
milestone at this point it's really sad
and so now there's divorce parties yeah
yeah what there's women throw parties
when they get divorced oh my God this is
just yeah it's absolutely absurd I just
like as a like as a Christian though I
really think like if there are
if there's like structures in place and
you're clear and and you you I guess
it's hard right because like I you a
woman can I don't know like watch I
don't know she can watch like Rollo to
Massey and she can like be singing his
praises and saying exactly what you want
to hear get the ring and then gain like
50 pounds and sit on her behind and then
take you for half if you leave and like
not give you sex yeah that's what that's
what women do a lot of them they get the
this is like I I have men I had this guy
he sent me this long email and it was so
sad it was like
um you know after watching your content
I think I was my wife's second choice
because
um after kids like I haven't slept with
her in two years and he's like I make
this much money I go to the gym I do
this I do this and I don't want to cheat
but I I feel I feel trapped in this
marriage and if I leave she's probably
gonna take a bunch of money but I would
say and he also was like I love her but
I like this I can't but I would again
like going back to what I said before oh
there's certain conditions that I go in
on and I'm very hard and fast on those
conditions if they're not met
then I'm out and if you take my money
all right I'll get more but I'm not
saying that to be arrogant like you got
to the place you got to right
and again you I don't I actually agree
with a lot of you you're probably
thinking what are you saying mate
because you're saying there's no
incentive but you still want to do it
yeah like call me crazy but
in a way that kind of makes me want to
do it even more I'm I'm a bit extreme
that way like I'll take on the challenge
let's go you know not if red flags like
I don't know for me if there's red flags
clear red flags why are you going to get
married yeah if a woman's not connecting
to a man I agree with you or a man's not
connecting to a woman why where is the
motivation to even think like I really
wanna I see this as a long-term thing I
agree with you that's what I'm saying
though like as long as the criteria are
met for me and are still met like I
would say to him I I would I always say
some like my friends I'm brutally honest
with them you know if they tell me like
they want to lose weight I just say like
move more eat less work out what you
need to do to to do that right and make
it easier for yourself and I think it's
the same I think when it comes to
relationships I think it helps both men
and women to take the emotions out of it
and think as robotically as possible
these are my requirements if my
requirements are not met I am gone that
is it and I think I know other thing is
women would have a lot more respect for
their men if the man had principles and
stuck by them I agree so if they go in
and say these are what my expectations
are right okay she takes some of your
money okay she takes the kids you're
gone right she might actually have the
most respect she's had for you in years
if you actually leave
I think if that that guy that sent you
that email she might actually respect
him for the for the first time maybe
ever if he left no I agree I think women
take advantage of men that they know
that they can yeah definitely and
um
yeah and that's the that's the crazy
thing is I I had a clip um go go viral
like a couple months ago where I just
said if your girl gains 100 pounds
before she's even had kids like you can
leave you don't have to put up with that
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible